>> BEE THE
TRAIL FOLLOWINE FORMER VICE
PRESIDENT WHO HAS MADE A SON
FINIHEN HIS BID FO
TION.
TO THETE
STARN .
Reporter: FOR FORMER VICE ESID
L  IRUT WA.
>> IT'S A SERIOUS ISSUE, ONE E
>> Reporter: HPEAL
IT'S THAVE A .
FER QUESTIONS ATUR LEVEL OF THE.
-COUNTP
FOR CANDIDATE PENCE.
JUSTHIWEEK, AS HE AIMS TO
HIT ALL 99 COUNTIES IN IOWA. >>?
>>NOW, I CAME TO
COLUVER THE LAST FEW
YEARS THAT I'M BUT
WE'RE NOT KNN WELL.
E ABLE T
OUR STORY,R LE RECORAND THURIL
PEOPLE OF IOWA AO GREAT
ESS.HE MIDWEST NTO IOVERR
AND PIZZA.
PENCE'S RED SPOT FOR
SLICE?
THE PIZZA RANCH, CHAIN WIT
TIOWA.
>>WANT TN THE IOWACAUCUSPE
SO-CALLEPIZZRANCH STRATE I08E T
ANAGER FOR THEN ESIDENCAN HOL  W
FRD AND WIN E 2008
IOWA CAUCUSES.THIS ROOM, BELIEV
CAMPAIGN HOWE TOO D
ARE WILLING TO COME ON A COLD
YOUR PERSON.
THE
RELATIONSHIPS ARE INOF
50, NORA.
orter: ITH RANCH
50 IO,
DIFFERENT REPUBLICAN CANDIDATE,
PENCE TAKEY AND ALL
QUESTIONS IM ABOUT HISROLE IRTIE
ON JANUARY 6th.WOION.E SPEAK T.
I WANT TO TELLDUE
ANOUNCED, PMP WAS HEN I
L WRONG.
I BELIEVE IT WITH ALeporter: TH,
O ASKED THE QUES>> IL LIKE HE
ALTERED HI WDER SUPPORTINCE AFTO
TOY?
HE HAST ONHICCUP. .
>> Reporter: BUT MEETING
ANGE AMY KLEIN'SIND. WELL, IOR
ALL OF THEEOOME THATN GOING TO